infiniti l lettres de menaces
intimidations les actes de violence liés
à la vaccination contre la colite
s'intensifie face à cela plusieurs
médecins s'inquiètent pour leur sécurité
on a reçu les mails et les menaces de
mort première étape la prochaine étape
c'est courant je vous laisse deviner la
prochaine étape c'est que quelqu'un
scientifique médecin une infirmière et
une aide soignante se fasse lyncher sur
twitter les appels à la haine contre des
médecins se multiplient dans des
vaccinodromes plusieurs soignons été
agressé verbalement et menacé
physiquement alors on alexander sa meule
qui est avec nous voilà qui ont qui
s'est fait agresser merci vous êtes
enseignant docteur en biologie
moléculaire vous avez été agressé à une
manifestation où jean paul hamon on
adore médecin généraliste président
d'honneur de la fédération des médecins
de france merci papa vous avez l'air
très en forme d'ailleurs jean-paul ça va
pas mal ouais je trouve pas très en
beauté main en main actionnaires
vivifiant en bretagne cet été c'est bien
très bien c'est important de le dire
olive olive notre citoyen engagé la yann
moix on adore également voilà merci à
nancy rire et voilà qui dit toujours
échoué on a fabriqué division en visio
regardez
salé fabrice tété ou fabrice chez lui à
lannion
merci
d'être là c'est la ville de lumière
ça s'appelle une division conférence
merci yahvé
shihri juste avant juste avant au départ
marquant de lâcher ce soir notre médecin
d'avoir ce doit être la faute de martin
voilà il vous a dit vous expliquer
pourquoi il sera pas là ce soir marquant
blachier je vais vous le dire
ici c'est un sujet qui lui tenait
énormément à coeur à martin il en a
parié de parler d'ailleurs avec la
production ce matin je vous le dis
maintenant lâché il faut savoir que
lui-même est au coeur de menaces et
d'intimidation très sérieuse des
agressions physiques parfois c'est assez
compliqué pour lui et il a préféré
décliner notre habitation par peur des
répercussions que savait qu'il vient
toujours il ne souhaite pas prendre de
risque on le comprend voilà et ont donc
on lui souhaite bon courage
j'espère qu'il reviendra nous voir mais
je vous dis il est extrêmement affecté
par ce qui se passe actuellement autour
de lui et voilà donc il n'a pas souhaité
venir ce soir parce que il devait venir
il a annulé au dernier moment il s'est
dit il a trop peur des répercussions
alors alexander saml merci d'être là
vous qu'est ce qui s'est passé bah moi
j'ai vécu à la fois des violences
physiques mais ça fait très longtemps
que je me fais menacés intimidés pour
moi les prises de position alors c'est
quoi votre iphone ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'au début de la pandémie j'étais
en contact avec des gens de hong kong
d'accord ce que je vais travailler sur
les gaz lacrymogènes je t'ai gilet jaune
j'étais très proche du moins les jeunes
et ils m'ont prévenu que dans une
population qui est des fientes comme
celle des jeunes par rapport aux
autorités il ya des profiteurs de la
pandémie qui vont arriver et qui vont se
servir un peu de ce genre de situation
parce qu'ils aient une défiance envers
les autorités pour prendre la place des
autorités d'accord et je me suis dit
tiens c'est extrêmement dangereux donc
je vais très vigilant et comme j'ai un
doctorat en biologie et que je
m'intéressais à la fraude scientifique
notamment je me suis intéressé beaucoup
à les papiers qui ont été rétractées par
notre ministre de la recherche frédéric
vidal papiers scientifiques qui ont été
rétractées ce qui est intéressant pour
une mise de la recherche bah je me suis
dit là bas la tiens on va je pense que
la pandémie va nous apporter son lot de
problèmes et de rétractation et j'ai été
un des premiers à avoir des gros
problèmes dans certaines publications
scientifiques notamment de didier raoul
tu es donc quand j'ai commencé à
m'exprimer sur les doutes que j'avais
sur cette publication bah j'ai très vite
eu des menaces des insultes et des
choses comme ça vous avez quoi comme
nani ça peut aller de on va te pendre on
va te tuer turon faut le jeter dans la
seine faut le à des trucs comme ça quoi
des appels direction mon téléphone bonne
chose et vous avez été agressé lors
d'une manifestation à lors d'une
manifestation j'ai une agression
physique aussi j'ai eu juste y en a une
qui a pas été filmée donc je n'ai pas de
preuve pour s'aménager je suis jetée en
direct donc la première c'est quelqu'un
que je connais bien que j'ai tenu un
discours qui était de dire que c'est un
vaccin expérimental
alors le mot expérimental a un sens et
là c'est faux il est pas expérimental en
tant que tel le vaccin on peut parler de
la phase 3 et 5 sur certaines choses
mais il est pas expérimental en tant que
tel et lorsqu'on se fait injecter le
vaccin on n'est pas en phase
expérimentale là ce qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai juste contester cette
phrase j'ai dit non le vaccin n'est pas
expérimental ça marche comme ça la
recherche ça fonctionne comme ça j'ai
essayé d'expliquer et pour avoir dit ça
bah ça a énervé des gens il y en a un
qui m'a pris par le col qui m'a poussé
contre un mur il a failli me frapper et
heureusement il ya d'autres personnes
qui sont intervenues au dernier moment
j'étais contre une barrière à deux
doigts de me prendre un pain dans la
gueule avec le mans et puis bah ouais
heureusement quelqu'un est intervenue
nos médecins sont-ils en danger regarder
on va qu'on va voir votre agression
aussi le 21 août dernier aux six mois
lors d'une manif contre le pass
sanitaires à la fin de la manif vous
avez voulu décrocher une pancarte que
vous jugiez manipulatrice on regarde et
vous êtes fait tomber thurien
pdg de facebook soit disant que des
[Musique]
parents me fera part parce que
c'est parti c'est des mensonges je t'ai
vu
des images assez violente on passe à la
dernière partie des missions animaux
est ce que les médecins sont en danger
pour vous jean paul hamon il y aura
toujours il y aura toujours quelqu'un
qui qui sera suffisamment abrutis ou
suffisamment allumé pour pour passer à
l'acte 1 on reçoit effectivement des des
messages du genre on aura ta peau on va
péter la gueule t'inquiète pas on
t'attend draps etc et avant-hier
certainement cabinet à 8h j'attendais
tranquillement que le feu passe au vert
pour pour traverser la route et il ya un
type qui est passé en trottinette
électrique et qui va traiter de nazis
alors il est du pot d'être en
trottinette électrique parce que courir
derrière mais franchement on voit on
voit que ja
il ya des risques sexuels et bon il ya
cent cinquante mille deux cent mille
personnes qui défilent il ya forcément
dans le lot quelques allumés qui sont
cicatrisées et ceux là vont passer à
l'acte donc
je veux dire j'ai vu jean castex sadi
qui disait on comprends les gens qui ont
peur et moi je comprends pas ce qu'il y
en a 150 mille deux cent mille qui
défilent et n'y a pas que des mauvais il
ya des gens c'est qu'ils ont peur qu'ils
se posent des questions et on peut pas
aussi
mais justement c'est ce qui est ce qui
est des skis et dénonçables c'est
vraiment l'exploitation du désarroi des
gens et ça pour soi pour sa petite
gloire personnelle soit pour récupérer
des ronds en défendant des gens dans des
procès soit pour faire grossir sans
micro parti politique en vue des
élections les modélisations sont là mais
les conséquences les conséquences
peuvent être terribles y en a toujours
un mec qui qui qui sortira un poignard
un couteau ou je ne sais quoi pour
pourra les trucider un soignant mais
jean-paul vous comprenez bien ça je le
comprends tout à fait bien sûr qu'il ya
des extrêmes et des extrémismes même là
mais on peut comprendre aussi les gens
qui ont peur les gens ici qui disent que
j'ai pas envie qu'on prenne la décision
pour moi de me faire vacciner j'ai peur
je ne sais pas trop je laissez moi
réfléchir ça on peut les comprendre si
ces gens là et dans les gens qui
défilent tous les samedis y a pas que
des hurluberlus dans les serres il ya
des gens aussi qui se posent des
questions et c'est vrai que voilà après
ces dérives la font très mal une fois de
plus bien sûr aux gens qui sont de
bonnes routes et qui pose des questions
guillaume évidemment moi je souhaite à
personne de se faire menacer de se faire
agresser en revanche ce qui me gêne avec
ce genre de situation c'est qu'on crée
un amalgame sarko montre des cas qui
heureusement sont des cas isolés et ont
fait passer tous les anti vaccins tous
les antilles parce qu'ils représentent
aujourd'hui des millions de personnes
pour des gens violents pour des gens
bêtes pour des gens menaçant ce qui je
pense n'est pas le cas comme le dit
cyril ya des gens qui expriment leurs
opinions de manière très pacifique et
des gens qui manifestent de manière très
pas si sûr et il fit pas question de ça
mais ça crée un amalgame malheureusement
oui le problème le problème il est que
bon les des menaces verbales on en a sur
les réseaux etc on sait on sait ça mais
des gens qui sont fragiles mentalement
encouragé par le discours haineux parce
que là vraiment à un discours haineux et
par les menaces ils vont passer à l'acte
s'agit clairement il a regardé dans des
accidents graves justement regarder sont
de plus en plus violents de certains
reçoit même des menaces de décapitation
regarder
mon traitement vous dit quoi c'est très
varié ça passe par les réseaux sociaux
sous forme de messages directs mais ça
passe également par des lettres
manuscrites avec des menaces qui sont
soit directement sur les personnes
concernées soit sur leurs familles bon
alors quelques fois c'est 18 c est qu on
essaie de vous avez un certain nombre de
choses on vous explique en particulier
et bien vous allez passer devant un
tribunal on sait pas très bien lequel
ils appellent ça nuremberg 2 et devant
lequel est bien on sera jugé et que
derrière il y aura une peine de mort et
que cette peine de mort pourrait être
soit la décapitation la pendaison enfin
ce genre de chose en plus il ya des
détails sur le délire est donc très
précis oui vous avez peur d'exercer
votre métier aujourd'hui à lectoure de
germes et et je suis enseignant je sais
ce que je fais mon activité annexe
j'ai pas vraiment peur moi j'aime pas
dire que j'ai peur et je suis plutôt
mécontent il ya une inquiétude on peut
se dire je suis en danger sa jeu j'en ai
conscience par contre j'ai pas envie de
céder à la peur c'est la première chose
et j'ai jamais céder à la peur sur eure
je veux juste ajouter une chose je pense
que c'est pas très bien de pointe
effectivement comme ça je suis très
d'accord avec ce discourt j'ai pas envie
qu'on pointe des personnes en dessous
l'axé je pense que ce qui importe ce
qu'on fait ici vous comprendre d'où ça
sort d'où sort cette défiance moi je
vais dans les manifs je trouve que le
patient ni terre n'est pas la bonne
méthode a bonne stratégie d'accord pour
arriver à la vaccination ça c'est mon
avis je vais dans les manifs anti pas
sanitaire et quand je parle aux gens je
leur pose la question pourquoi est ce
que tu fais vague pas vacciner parce que
moi j'aimerais bien ne pas que ce soit
une obligation mais que tu sois
convaincu c'est ça et quand j'écoute
quand j'écoute les gens malheureusement
il ya des tas de mensonges qui ressorte
qui sont pas des mensonges de ces
personnes qui sont des mensonges
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de
régulation cette parole scientifique il
ya une parole scientifique on va citer
tel ou tel expert qui nous chante mais
qui est en fait un vrai des informateurs
notoire qui a déjà des tas de
publications rétracter on sait que c'est
un fraudeur les scientifiques la comité
scientifique c que ce sont des rigolos
c'est 50 mais mes versions on entend
tellement de choses qui a des langues
qui disent que ça peut être des vérités
jean-paul vous vous faites beaucoup de
télévisions et de rien comment ça
commence à être connu est ce que vous
avez peur parfois comme mehdi un mec qui
vous a traité dans la rue de wayne on va
c'est à dire que nos envies on vit avec
ça ça fait ça fait quand même quelques
années que j'exerce ça m'est arrivé de
d'être menacée
c'est vrai c'était ya une trentaine
d'années il ya un type complètement
givrés qui est quelqu'un qui a tapé avec
l'âge contre la porte du cabinet j'ai
ouvert la porte j'ai vu que la secrète
arrêté inquiète je suis allé voir et
puis comme j'ai vu me gaver une vache
moi je suis allé chercher au marteau
réflexe j'ai envie de caoutchouc et je
vais foncer dessus et l'amex et barré
mais mais mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que bon ça ça ça peut arriver
on doit être confronté à un type qui est
fou et qui passent à l'acte il est loin
je suis loin de dire que tous les gens
sont des furieux il ya des gens qui sont
dans les dents des manifestations ils
sont vaccinés et puis laissez les gens
majoritairement ils sont pas violents
mais quand on voit ce qui s'est passé
quand contre crémieux par exemple 1 à
domicile de crémieu ces compressions
inadmissible je voulais hélas les
menaces il faut se méfier si vous voulez
ce que moi je m'en sincèrement que les
menaces sur les réseaux sociaux doivent
être sanctionnés les pouvoirs publics
doivent prendre leurs responsabilités
on doit protéger on doit protéger les
soignants il faut qu'on vaccine
massivement les gens c'est clair et ce
qui s'est passé aux antilles où les gens
étaient vaccinés à 20% où il ya eu
c'est ce second film en 7 c'est ce
nouveau ces pandémies aux antilles alors
que 20 % des gens étaient seulement
vaccinés et j'ai croisé hier professeur
carli qui sortait qui aurait en
réadaptant ricky m'a dit mais on a
rapatrié jean paul on a rapatrié deux
airbus de gens de réanimation plus de
100 personnes qu'on a rapatrié des
antilles on a on a fait de la publicité
pour les 4-5 premier conte rapatriés on
n'a pas dit que derrière l'arrêt a été
débordé donc clairement 95% des gens qui
sont en réanimation sont des gens qui
sont pas vaccinés donc c'est vrai que à
un moment où on s'énerve on aurait envie
de trouver les bons arguments pour que
les gens soient rassurés se fassent
vacciner etc mais c'est vrai que c'est
un peu énervant alors lui il va chercher
vraiment aller dans une valeur de 2 mois
je dirais pas la question quand vous
poserai la question que vous pose ce
soir nos médecins sont-ils en danger
face aux anti vaccin il ya des menaces
et des intimidations quand on entend
tout ça au livre tu dis quoi il ya
quelque chose qui me dérange en fait
dans le discours qui portait là parce
que y'a pas que les médecins ou les pros
vrac ce qu'ils sont qui sont accusés qui
reçoivent des menaces moi je reçois des
menaces aussi tous les jours on m'a déjà
interpellé dans des manifestations très
violemment aujourd'hui quoi on t'as fait
quoi du mois obama on m'a complètement
attrapé on m'a fait sortir d'une
manifestation parce que ça plaisait pas
que ma présence soit là aujourd'hui les
menaces y sont des deux côtés en fait et
il ya autre chose qui me dérange quand
même parce que je pense que et à la
menace comme on disait vermaele la
menace physique alors et je les condamne
à je condamne toutes les sortes de
menaces envers qui que ce soit je les
condamne fortement mais par contre quand
je vois
alexander qui a à nice qui est en train
d'arracher des panneaux sur des grilles
je pense que ça c'est une menace aussi
parce que c'est une menace contre la
liberté d'expression des gens qui
veulent afficher des choses et on n'a
pas à le faire et puis on n'a
jamais oublié votre monde et en vol
quand j'envoie lamont excusez moi jean
paul hamon quand même condamné femme
convoquée le 2 juin par l'ordre des
médecins pour des menaces verbales
contre francis lalanne en insultant la
brute et alors
mais ça fait part dé quand même des
menaces ça fait
s'apprêtait pas gelé pas menacée je les
qualifiés
je les qualifiés et alors les et mes
collègues médecins m'ont dit écoute jean
paul qui doit être poursuivi par l'ordre
parce que tu as fait une erreur de
diagnostic parce que l'abruti c'est
vraiment très faible c'était une période
souvenez-vous où les réanimations de
paca étaient débordés qu'on commençait
déjà à délocaliser les des gens de
réanimation et là il y avait une
manifestation sur une place avec des
gens qui étaient à tout touche et vous
avez quelqu'un qui est en train de dire
ne portait pas de masque embrassez-vous
ça c'est un criminel c'est pas abruti
c'est criminel donc si vous voulez c'est
vrai que si si on veut faire taire si on
va faire taire les médecins alors ce
moment là effectivement il y aura
peut-être des moyens plus radicaux mais
là en l'occurrence la banque
à des personnes qui veulent faire taire
les médecins sont bons c'est clair que
mon faire taire les gens qui s'expriment
la regarder blachier qui indique qu'à
pas la langue dans sa poche
il a été il a été menacé au point
d'avoir peur
moi j'ai quelques années de vol g et ça
va c'est bon j'ai pas trop la trouille
je prends des précautions mais mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu énervant
c'est un peu énervant on est dans un
monde complètement anormale où on n'est
pas fous les deux côtés allez les gars
on n'est pas un bruit
c'est c'est pas c'est pas bien de
d'avoir enlevé les mener enfin peu voilà
vous avez fait de la provocation en
enlevant les pancartes c'est juste qu'il
voulait faire de la démagogie non je
vais essayer de contextualiser un peu
parce que fait que je trouve un peu
dommage que olive olive que j'apprécie
ne sont pas solidaires face à une
agression comme ça mais sur cette
pancarte précisément ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la manif avait continué avait
plus la manif et rient plus personne
pour moi je ne savais pas qu'il avait
encore des gens qui étaient derrière un
arbre que j'avais pas vu ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'ils ont laissé leurs
pancartes sur place et qui avait un
petit vieux qui était en train d'essayer
de déchiffrer les pancartes j'arrivais
pas à les lire qu'ils avaient du mal à
les lire bernard manqué et non mais il
avait du mal avait il se rapprocher
comme ça il avait du mal et et je
regardais jeu je dis rien je le regarde
et puis là il n'était pas dans la manif
ans et un passant l'a un peu petit et
puis regardez ici à je voulais me faire
vacciner la semaine prochaine là
maintenant ça me fait hésiter tout ça
est ce qu avait marqué son apparition
remarquée sur la pancarte il y avait en
rien aux codes malone un robert malone
il y avait vélo il y avait des noms que
je passe mon temps à des bunkers c'est
des personnes qui est malheureusement
instrumentalise la science pour faire
soit du buzz de la politique des choses
mais qui ne parle pas du tout qu'ils
sont plus du tout sur le terrain
scientifique sont vraiment pas sur le
terrain scientifique pour donner un
exemple ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis sur mon esprit c'est important de
voir pour par reproduire les erreurs des
états unis on est en train d'importer en
france quelque chose de dramatique qui
s'est passé aux états unis aux états
unis il ya eu un arrêt psg pas si
quelqu'un ici connaît à aps je pense que
personne ne connaisse à association of
physicians and surgeons
super accents outil fait c'est une
association américaine de médecins parce
que physician ses médecins en anglais
mme g faux amis et seul john c le
chirurgien
évidemment tout le monde convergent donc
ça des sergents donc c'est cette
association qu'est ce qu'elle a fait bah
en fait elle a commencé à dire que les
homosexuels basse affirmant longtemps
parce que c'est pas bien être homosexuel
elle a commencé à dire que bah ouais le
sida en fait c'est pas un virus ça
n'existe pas c'est parce que les
homosexuels c'est tous des toxicomanes
et donc du coup ils chantent le sida
parce qu'ils sont toxicomanes donc en
fait c'est des gens qui sont extrêmement
conservateur alors on mal voie de l'être
on peut être qu'on signe patent qu'ils
envoient des idées qui sont parfois et
qui vont sortir du cadre scientifique et
instrumentalisé leur autorité parce que
c'est des médecins ça exactement ils ont
donc on se dit c'est vrai et qui vont
dire ça et c'est eux qui sont impliqués
par exemple dans ce fameux scandale que
souvent des gens invoquent le scandale
des opioïdes on a pu inscrire
massivement des opioïdes et dans la
banquise regarder lorsque l'industrie
pharmaceutique machin machin ben
justement c'était un espèce de l'est
sont les prescrire à l'américaine il
disait laisser les médecins à prescrire
alors justement les fabriquent des
vidéos qui est assez énervé parce que
vous dites vous le dit fabrice di vizio
bonsoir fabrice ah oui là
ça va ça va chez les bleus car il sert
achille emana oui fabrice est plutôt
plus calme que d'habitude moi j'ai une
question pour jean paul année
parce que j'adorais il a dit qu'il a dit
n'est là ni sa mort elle et je voudrais
juste savoir en fait est ce que vous
voudriez fait moi aussi j'ai eu peur je
suis pas venu juge partis très loin de
vous est ce que je voulais pas me faire
cogner en tant qu' responsable est ce
que vous voulez le cogner jean paul
hamon ah ouais alors ça ça vraiment
j'adore dans les saveurs si vous voulez
vous avez posé une question je vais y
rester
vous avez pas vous avez une question je
vais
[Rires]
qu'est ce que dit jean paul à moi
ne pas se faire vacciner pardon mais ça
n'allait pas bien jouer les
irresponsables heures
alors jean paul répondait oui c'est un
matin à matin de bonne heure un dimanche
matin j'étais interviewé sur une
surenchère
april division
division étaient à la messe et donc il
n'a pas entendu ce que j'ai dit est donc
effectivement
effectifs dont je peux remplacer
donc
j'étais quand même très énervé sûr pour
les gens qui comme filet de se faire
vacciner et
et donc là j'ai dit une phrase il va
falloir il va falloir sortir la boîte à
claques et
va falloir il va falloir sortir il va
falloir sortir la boîte à claques et
cogner sur les antilles vague c'est à
dire que ça voulait dire s'il faut tenir
alors il ya des avocats en mal de
publicité qui ont pris ça au premier
degré et qui ont dit et qui ont dit
est-ce que je suis une personne sur
lequel vous devriez cogner alors écoutez
ça m'a pas étonné de vous parce que quoi
qu elles sont mauvaises fois vous êtes
bien en forme donc là moi c'était un
truc du second degré a dit et j'avais
dit on va pas laisser comme ça les gens
c'était un moment où la vaccination
patiner et que et que les et que la
laine lapide la pandémie se développer
que les réanimations était plein et donc
et voilà donc et ça a été largement
diffusée et déformé par fabrice deux
jours connaît sa responsabilité il est
habitué
ça c'est certainement parce que c'est
tout
il n'a pas dit que ça perso je me tape
un vrai succès chez les patriots après
avoir dit sur scène il fallait sortir la
boîte à claques pour les non vaccinés
bravo alors ça c'est pas de la violence
ça me fait rire parce que pour l'instant
ouais le nexus one à l'indignation votre
ligne à sion cher m vous pouvez vous la
mettre d'accord
à la
sam à la saba et ça m'a bien ça va bien
effectivement pourquoi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est que vous avez
vous avez repris le tweet que jamais
vous avez reprises que j'avais dit vous
l'avez déformés vous l'avez vous l'avez
vous êtes plus dépouillé ouais ouais
ouais je sais bien je dis seulement 1
vous l'avez vous l'avez des formes et ça
se finit à la vie alors allez-y n'est
pas fini le conte du bien le camp du
bien est ce que vous connaissez bien
pour le nombre d'amis à barreaux un
barreau
doubler celle d'octobre et madame
organisateurs réanimateur qui
effectivement est un ami de christian
les mal du tout le groupe no fake med
effectivement qui gravitaient le dr
marty
j'ai voulu dire ce qu'il écrit sur
twitter les retraités pourraient
décliner retraités pouvait dégager des
toons ce serait chouette ils sont une
partie du problème de qu'ils ont créée
et entretenue ce système de très longue
date j'ai pas fini
après rien ne dit qu'un de dit que je
les accepterai andrea parce qu'en fait
on verra c'est moi le chef c'est moi qui
décide de petits je prends donc excusez
moi mais quand on parle de la violence
des 9 axes ça c'est quoi premier élément
mais effectivement quand on est médecin
dans ce pays aujourd'hui et qu'on
appartient au camp du bien on a le droit
de tout dire de tout faire de vouloir
mettre des claques aux gens qui doivent
val qui me passe avec ce n'est pas ce
que vous comprenez si on peut pas les
convaincre que les contraintes et
ensuite pour l'instant les copains je
vous rappelle un truc que tout le monde
a oublié c'est que le mec qui se bat
avec des gars du garde du corps et dont
les gamins vont à l'école avec des
gardes du corps c'est moi
que quoique à bien en tout cas pour
l'instant quand on me parle
effectivement de violence les médecins
sont ils en danger passe aux antilles
vax et ben moi ce que je vous propose
c'est avec des missions spéciales savoir
si les anti vaccins qu'on veut frapper
sont eux aussi en danger face à des
médecins qui concrètement ne veulent pas
d admettre aurea qui veulent par
ailleurs effectivement sortir la boîte à
claques et les frapper parce que vous
comprenez stable dimanche matin et que
le dimanche on apprenait fatigué et
quand on est fatigué après on peut
frapper les gens alors excusez moi mais
la connerie elle a pas de conte oui il
faut condamner les violences verbales
que celle que tu bissap en lambeaux de
personnes dans un camp comme dans
l'autre et quand j'entends ici jean paul
hamon et les autres
beugnet plaint ouvertement d'avoir suivi
des menaces après avoir assumé
pleinement jusqu'à dire que je te mets
carême je pense mais n'a pas de relation
que sais-je que c'est oui excusez moi
mais la violence si vous allez
maintenant merci c'est fini on peut
parler là parce que là franchement il
n'y a aucun aucun réanimateurs leurs
animateurs excédé qu'à passer qu'à
passer des mois avec des horaires pas
possible avoir cannes et les gens à
réaliser des arrêts lui des gens que le
réanimateur puisse avoir un moment
désespoir en tournée
au savon bien là
ça va bien un correctif qui l'a qu'il
aille faire un seulement une demi
journée en réanimation il va voir ce que
c'est un devoir 95% des gens d'en
vacciner que légende des antilles ont
été obligés de choisir quand le
cheschire des brotteaux entre ce qu'ils
allaient réaliser ou pas
donc là là le réalisateur de leurs
animateurs excédé puisse dire que le
rénovateur et cd puisse avoir cette
phrase mais personne aucun médecin ne
refusera de soigner qui que ce soit vous
le savez bien on peut parler de ça comme
ça entre nous quand les mecs sont
excédés alors effectivement sur le
réseaux sociaux pour se méfier mais mais
là c'est vrai que c'est insupportable
quand on se dit mais quand on voit des
gens qui meurent d'aidé dit il de 50 ans
qui sont pas vaccinés et quand on voit
que le lot des gens qui sont en
réanimation 95% que carly nous dit qu'il
a rapatrié cents personnes des antilles
100 personnes en réanimation
l'équivalent de deux airbus j'imaginais
donc cesser c'est vrai que quand les
gens ne réalisent pas l'importance de la
vaccination concon qu'on compare ce qui
s'est passé là il ya eu de la
contamination énorme en france mais les
les réanimateurs n'ont pas été débordée
cette fois ci alors qu aux antilles et à
tahiti les gens ont été débordés donc si
vous voulez c'est clairement entre la
vaccination on dit c'est du gâchis et
les gens sont désespérés de voir ça
c'est tout vous ne vous a pas entendu la
droite vous pensez que non les médecins
ne sont pas en danger alors déjà je
parle en connaissance de cause parce que
si j'avais touché 10 euros à chaque fois
que j'ai reçu des menaces de mort serait
multi milliardaire ouais ouais c'est pas
les médecins qui sont en danger si les
médecins médiatisé qui sont allongés
ciblées je veux bien qu'on nous dise que
les hôpitaux sont débordés j'en ai un
peu marre de voir les médecins plus
souvent sur les plateaux de télévision
dans la bonne a lancé un pavé d'accord
simplement on a besoin d'eux je le droit
de terminer simplement cyril ce qui se
passe c'est que quand le veuille ou non
il ya certains médecins qui ont pris
goût à la lumière qui ont pris goût aux
médias et dont la tête a un petit peu
enflée et
je vais tout simplement que ce n'est pas
contre les médecins que les gens veulent
si vous voulez une espèce de noblesse
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus la noblesse de
sens et la noblesse de la médiatisation
de la notoriété une sorte de haine de la
notoriété qui sait que des anonymes aime
se défouler m menacé quand vous
travaillez auprès des policiers vous
vous apercevez que l'immense majorité
des gens qui menacent ne passent jamais
à l'acte et l'immense majorité des gens
qui passent à la plus d'un seul pas
menacée avant alors après se trouve la
question est-ce que ça ça vaut des
insultes et des bagarres des peines de
mort vachin s'en prendre aux médecins et
quelque chose d'inadmissible pour moi
les médecins c'est quelque chose sacrée
on menace pas de mort quelqu'un dont la
vie est dédié à rendre la vie ou à
guérir les gens simplement ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que tant qu'on touche pas à
des sujets vraiment fondamentaux comme
la religion quelle qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs ou autre on s'aperçoit
simplement que c'est des crises
passagères exactement comme le type qui
dans ses voitures vous insultent parce
qu'ils essaient qui l'envoie là mais
vous auriez très bien pu aller boire un
verre cinq minutes plus tôt avec lui
mais sa venue de plus tard il ya un
effet protecteur et dévastateurs d'un
soulagement par l'anonymat vous et moi
moi j'ai reçu par exemple des photos de
larmes qu'elle aime buts et le calibre
les bat louis fouquet photo j'avais eu
le menu de ce qui m'attendait j'attends
encore en fait j'ai tous les apprentis
savoir les apprentis un menu pour vous
dire ce qu'on avait volé ce que vous
allez vous savez ça
médecins comme martin lâché que
j'apprécie particulièrement c'est que en
fait ça va passer on porte plainte la
première fois la deuxième au bout de
douze fois on s'aperçoit qu'il ya passé
mais non mais oui on va vers les gîtes
et bien oui bah bienvenue au club c'est
pas la peine de venir pleurnicher sur
les plus tôt ça va vous arriver encore
pendant quelques mois et moi j'en suis
désolé je trouve ça lamentable mais
malheureusement c'est le revers de la
médaille de la surexposition il ne se
passera rien le risque est minime là où
monsieur armand a raison c'est qu'on
peut pas on peut pas s'empêcher de
penser qu'un illuminé et cora mal
interprété quelque chose ricochet
infinie puisse passer à l'acte même si
la probabilité et d'un milliardième mais
quand on n'est pas sur des choses
fondamentales personnes l'insultent à
laon menée contre le peuple pour contre
un vaccin donc moi je ne serai pas à
votre place terrorisée je viendrai un
petit peu moins sur les plateaux de télé
pendant quelques mois c'est alexander
keith vous répondre je me sens que tu
peut agresser là quand on dit
pleurnicher terroristes extrêmement
violent alors que je n'ai ni pleurnicher
ni dit qu'elle était terrorisée va faire
au sens la rafle à travers ce que ce qui
arrive à certaines personnes médiatisé
je peux vous dire que moi je ne suis pas
très médiatisé je suis pas très connu
non c'est un j'ai fait j'ai fait
quelques uns tendance énormément
d'attenté j'ai quand même été très
soutenue par des petits médecin anonyme
sur les réseaux sociaux qui parfois on
s'en faut le voir rien du tout qui
viennent me parler en privé et qui me
disent j'ai peur ouais les petits
médecin cessa pas les grands sa saison
port-la-nouvelle inverse je veux arrêter
ce qui se passe il faut arrêter je pense
comme toi d'avoir peur vous avez raison
la part on a peur de la peur d'accord de
la peur de la peur de la combattre la
peur par contre on est dans une
situation je suis tout à fait d'accord
il faut le pire ennemi c'est la peur
finalement c'est ce qui nous paraît la
meilleure mais il faut il faut la
vaincre cette peur il faut pas en avoir
il faut faut arriver à aller au dessus
mais faut aussi se dire dans le passage
à l'acte dans l'extrémisme il ya des ya
des variables des mécanismes qui
existent et en servant le narratif ça
c'est vrai il ya un narratif qui
influencent oui à la au passage à l'acte
actuellement nous avons un narratif qui
existe et qu'il faut et et que je ne
vois pas assez condamné de manière
générale par le camp des anti axe ou
anti passe je trouve qu'il faudrait
vraiment condamner totalement le
discours qui dit
des traitements existent le gouvernement
où je sais pas quelle autorité les
médecins veulent empêcher les gens de se
soigner et imposer un vaccin de big
pharma qui est un poison et qui va tuer
tout le monde ce discours là ce narratif
là il fait extrêmement peur à certaines
personnes et il fait que certaines
personnes sont prêtes à passer à l'acte
mais séparatif là il faut essayer de le
contrer personne au sens où vous
l'entendez haut niveau à lèvres a
décapité pour une histoire de vaccins
par contre le climat qui règne autour de
cela fait qu'effectivement je me mets
dans votre situation c'est intolérable
et inacceptable mabile est tellement
faible que vous devriez dans le sud
auxquels je suis d'accord avec toi par
contre c'est quand même super marrant
parce que
seule personne que je vois à la télé moi
depuis un an et demi pas toi puisque tu
passais pas la télé ou même sur les
réseaux mais on a un médecin qui est là
avec nous et qu'on voit sur tous les
plateaux de télé qui nous envoie la peur
c'est quand même beau
ça fait un an et demi qu'on essaie de
faire croire à tout le monde que tout le
monde allait mourir de de ce virus alors
qu'aujourd'hui on est totalement mission
est grand dieu merci qui touchent qu'une
certaine catégorie du personnel sont en
effet les chiffres à pouvoir parce que
quand on voit comment que ça a été fait
on n'a jamais entendu sur des plateaux
télé bas cette maladie tue 0.50 0 4 %
des gens qui finissent en réanimation
enfin le syndrome de la peur c'est vous
les deux morts et des moins spectateur
un crédit s'il vous plaît me à 52%
envoyer les médecins sont en danger non
à 40 ans mais division voulu rajouter
quelque chose
il joue a indiqué shawn le seul qui pour
l'instant a reçu des menaces de mort et
une condamnation pour ça en tout cas en
prose et où il fait une mission que j'ai
tissé round quand même ça rajoute a reçu
des menaces de mort de la part d'un
médecin identifier quelqu'un condamné
les si j'écoute jean-paul à non c'est
parce qu'il avait beaucoup de travail
donc quand on est médecin qu'on a
beaucoup de travail on peut le dimanche
matin insulter les autres on peut dire
oh non vaccinés il faut leur mettre des
claques quand même ensuite à vous les
menaces viennent encore la mairie annexe
je termine ton et des animateurs on peut
se permettre de dire sur twitter qu'on
accueillera pas les gens mais ça c'est
quand on est médecin mais quand de
l'autre on n'est pas n'a pas le
privilège d'être médecin on n'a pas le
droit d'être fatigué on n'a pas le droit
d'être excédé depuis un an et demi on
n'a pas le droit d'avoir des problèmes
de famille j'ai parfois effectivement
font déborder un vase déjà trop plein ça
on n'a pas le droit parce que dans ce
pays aujourd'hui comme l'a très
justement dit and watch il n'y a qu'une
seule catégorie médecin sait mais les
médecins médiatiser les médecins qui au
quotidien sont poursuivis par l'ordre
pour prescrire qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
la violence institutionnelle
et c'est ces gens qu'ils ont cautionné
depuis des mois quand même on va se
retrouver demain
avec fabrice merci jean paul devrait car
voulait dire un petit mot oui non mais
c'est vrai que là quand je dis sortir la
boîte à claques qui est évident que
c'était du dieu second c'était du second
degré lui là il a il a repris sa au
premier degré il a exploité il a
retraités etc et c'est vrai qu'après je
me suis fait allumer de première mais
bon moi j'ai les derniers mètres que
j'ai cogné il était en 6e doit donc ça
fait un moment a donc ça va faut faut
arrêter de déconner avec lui